[Music]
two decades had passed since the
creation of both species the war had
begun in the first two movies we were
told vampires have been around for at
least fourteen centuries vampires have
been fighting werewolves for at least
eight centuries so I'm pretty sure the
math is wrong somewhere also every one
of these movies starts with narration
but it's more the screenwriters talking
to each other and saying do I have that
right also understand this I've watched
all the underworld movies but I already
kind of forgot what they were fighting
about something about Otto von Bismarck
and land rights to all sauce Lorraine
pretty sure that was mentioned once or
twice
that's a newborn inside a werewolf cage
right there in an effort not to show
this baby's weirdly massive penis I'll
explain that the narrator says Victor
wanted to kill this kid but didn't
because all the people he has second
thoughts about figure into the plot of
these movies later Victor closes the
door on a human baby and his dead mother
I guess assuming the baby will figure
out this living business by himself over
the years this child grew he possessed a
strength and focus that the ones before
him did not including all the people who
constructed this fight scene full of
cuts and faceless assholes Victor would
use Lucian's infectious blood to his
benefit are you still talking do we need
you anymore
this transformation requires about 245
more cuts than John Landis used in an
American Werewolf in London also I'm not
sure how they figured Lucian's bite
would create more Lycans just like it
order that it might require a little bit
more of a special process than a simple
bite but I guess those medieval assholes
knew what they were doing back then I
don't know who this is or why I should
care all I know is if you see a knight
and you're not sure who it is because of
the helmet it's probably because that
person is a woman and man when you find
that out won't you be sexist looks like
Bruce Almighty has been working his
magic tonight I get the sense that the
entire Twilight series was created
because of underworld I think Stephenie
Meyer watched the movie in 2003 and said
I can do something just as she is that
and put a love story in it and she was
done with the whole series by the time
the credits were over discount Kate
Beckinsale also let's film a chapter and
a barely successful franchise without
the main character or the actress and
see how that goes also that this is
Sonja she's a lot less blonde than she
was in those horrible flashbacks in the
first movie and why does she seem way
more badass in this movie than the first
one which seemed to portray her simply
is a damsel in distress what a credit to
your race
that's compliment racist Jesus Christ
you assholes candle much you got candles
in places you don't even need candles
also how did the overabundance of
candles and this shot lead to lighting
like this and how do they cast this
ethereal blue look throughout the room
you will learn the dance of politics to
be ruthless and cunning movie inspires
the plot a brave but they changed the
vampires and werewolves to bears I get
that these guys are slaves and this is a
horrible situation and everything but
the Freddy's guys building it seems like
everyone was directed to either carry a
rock or put down sandbags or use an axe
to simply perform the act of working I
might be more sympathetic to their
plight if I realized they were building
Victor's master bathroom or something I
know I called out the cups Ilan already
but goddamn this is a dude whippin
another dude it's like they didn't have
a budget for stage fighting in this
movie I'll today ah the grass on which
we graze if we could not protect our
humans that makes us look weak this
woman walked all the way from here to
finally say her line and that's the only
line she gets and I guess she's
someone's cousin looking for a sad card
or something and how would you project
strength
unfortunately Bill Nye suffered an
affliction playing Davy Jones after two
Pirates of the Caribbean movie Stein
occasionally still reads his lines in
other movies that way ruby delights and
making us think this is some sort of
scary moment for Lucien but it's
actually just Rhona Mitra here to sex
him this must be some epic thing to keep
fading to and from black so many times
during it mixing your fear of sex with
Heights also acrophobic and also in this
situation who's giving the dog about
also this is the rare Jesus Christ pose
sex technique that's impregnating all
the ladies these days leave Sonya is
gonna make it seem like it's a big deal
for her to leave this place when she
clearly hates her dad and the councilman
never follows the rules these dumbasses
after being careful of private cliffs
decide to risk being seen together at
any time and this guy from Lock Stock
and Two Smoking Barrels just happens to
be here of all places to see it this guy
shoots an arrow into the air telling the
castle they need extra people to escort
the nobles who just arrived but why did
they send only two guards in the first
place and why would they stop them in
the middle of werewolf country
Eddie Sonya your father has ordered you
to stay behind but of course you never
listen to your father
so I don't know why he even bothers with
these orders at least werewolves buried
in the ground what are they
cicadas this movie has the return of all
your favorite characters except the one
that will sell ticket to the box office
these were wolves turned into Gophers
for this movie it's actually insane they
built these tunnels just to be able to
attack from the ground below scream
diplomacy on the body find them all and
just do it in the middle of the woods
there's no way setting that many fires
near trees could be dangerous don't you
like people when you fell it was an easy
prediction to make since I'm the
designated torturer guy one full minute
of torture that would make the passion
of the christ' feel sorry for it also
there is no way they aren't telling the
Christ story through Lucien here from
his unusual birth to the weird cross
like way he had sex on a cliff a minute
ago and now this and while that may seem
deep and everything remember almost 75%
of movies find a way to compare their
protagonists to Christ by my count
that's 21 victor would later have a
child that starred on Sesame Street
continued why does Victor even need to
tell the sadistic bastard who's whipping
him right now to continue isn't that why
that asshole is 4 or is this just a
counting problem I will not bite don't
say it much god damn it no Tennessee
knows about us I have no idea I mean we
were so careful walking together out in
the open what could have gone wrong with
all but let me try already already her
is this what you want
are there really no guards down here who
can hear this coloman thinks he will
study others he said that during
Lucian's with it and you've never taken
that guy seriously but now when it's too
late that's when you decide he's not so
foolish after all and you decide to kill
Lucien now two minutes let me get this
straight
this guy has dirt on Lucien and Sonya
but he couldn't use it at all because he
felt Victor would not be grateful so
without blackmail Sonya gives Tanis her
council seat in exchange for him helping
Lucien escape
honestly Tanis knowing about Lucien and
Sonja's affairs pretty worthless overall
the only plot significance it brings is
that they know they can approach him
with a deal and that's it quite honestly
I don't know why Sonya herself can't
orchestrate the escape without Tanis but
whatever right some of the others will
come with me status interest of the
human race who could forget those guys
such characters they left such an
indelible mark on this movie and who are
they again - your life waiting beyond
these walls my side I mean we've known
each other for six hours but you seem ok
luckily for Lucian's plan this guy did
not check the cells from above and he's
able to easily hide and tear this guy
apart he stupidly walks it
Lucien keeps the prisoners quiet for
these two guards but now in the they're
not here on like a motion a minute ago
what do you want to bet some clumsy
asshole is gonna
god damn it movie was way uninterested
in giving us the suspense version of
this action scene preferring to go with
the surprise method of attack and giving
us this book where we have no idea where
anyone is or what's happening or why
this movie hates us so much bloody hell
do you see how frustrating watching this
movie is 15 cuts for one simple action
there were two editors on this movie and
I'm beginning to think that they were
paid by the cut to tell you the truth I
had no idea what these guys were doing
here but then I realized they're
vampires and they're burning in the
so-called Sun that's out right now but
this movie has done so little to show
the vampire culture of the castle it
really took me a minute to figure out
what's happening apparently nobody had
any question as to whether they would
survive this jump I mean they became
likens like yesterday right don't you
think they might have some reservations
Victor upon hearing about Lucian's
escape went to this middle of nowhere
door in the side of the rock which was
built for this movie so the Victor could
see Lucien escape where is the key I
gave you for this he must have made
another one or stay with me now Tanis
unlock Lucien scholar and then simply
came back here with the key to pack up
the story later or got somebody else to
bring the key back and even though we
know that's not what happened this is
the flimsiest alibi ever well someone's
all alien 3 or the lost world but do you
leave me no choice here comes the blurry
ass music video of memories somehow
conveniently remembered in the
third-person Justice eg she could leave
him here this guy thinks that after all
the trouble song you went through to
help these guys escape she turned around
and deceived them so that they could be
caught again Sonya has been arrested
good thing there was this handmaiden
that we saw one time before in this
movie and I don't think had any speaking
lines but was well trusted enough to
know exactly where Lucien would be at
this moment so she could give him the
news they focus on this like it's
something so crazy for a vampire to be
doing drinking blood that's insane idol
guarding now all Lucien was told was
that Sonya was arrested he didn't know
she was still in a room or anything but
he went straight here anyway by the way
this movie continues the grand tradition
of vampires werewolves weapons only this
time it's in medieval times where
weapons are even more boring than the
ones they use in modern underworld
movies I see it started raining because
mother nature knows what a dramatic
fight were about to have on our hands
underworld 3 steals the stupid method of
trying to blow up the protagonist from
the rock
that's one how about all of them go
ahead and try and keep up with us go
ahead I dare you I double dare you
motherfucker keep up with this one time
in fact let me just add 10 cents but the
action scene nonsense going on in this
movie these guys take turn punching
Lucien with their fists but apparently
have no need to punch him with swords or
knives or something that might end his
life whatever what a dumbass guy was a
dick anyway whoever he was call up your
bed for the sake of your grandchildren
it was probably the cliffhanger sex that
did it sperm travel with heightened
awareness when being shot through a
front Venus also Sonya thinks her dad
will in any way give leniency because
she's carrying a half like and half
vampire in her tummy sure this castle
has a twisting path full of different
little dungeon cells but let's put
Lucian and Sonya right next door to each
other
more than twenty more seconds of more
whipping even more sunroof opens and I'm
wondering didn't this execution happen
in front of everybody when they were
flashing back in the first movie this
movie apparently divorced the first
movie because of creative differences so
when the Sun burns these bodies why does
it keep a fully intact burned body there
she was completely disintegrating
earlier at the very least the Judgment
Day style ignition should have freed her
from her restraints right
such ma9 Victor should have killed
Lucien about 61 times in this movie but
now he's asking some asshole to fetch
his knives which I'm assuming means more
torture this movie is making it seem
like the werewolves need a full moon to
change but haven't we seen them do it
without that before actually yes in the
first underworld there was one line
about how the full moon no longer held
sway and werewolves could change it will
and that suggests during these early
days they couldn't do that you expect me
to remember that well I guess I did but
after two movies of changing it will
couldn't you at least give me a reminder
I'm guessing this is supposed to be
poetic Lucian looking down from the wall
where he used to kill werewolves if they
got too close but now he's looking for
them to save him but I'm kind of amazed
there wasn't some descent in the world
wolf community over this guy who killed
so many of their race even if he was
ordered to do so yeah there was one
thing that always bothered me about the
underworld series is that it wasn't Lord
of the Rings enough why aren't all these
guys changing into werewolves right now
it's the only reason raised is not
turning into a full-on werewolf because
underworld fans need to be able to
recognize him or is it because the
effects budget was strapped also affects
budget yeah there was a clown car full
of prisoners in the cell isn't there
meanwhile I'm pretty sure there are at
least two empty cells they could have
divvied up to prevent overcrowding I
guess running up these stairs finally
made Ray's want to change into a
werewolf movie decides to casually show
us vampires walking off a ledge and
falling like that's normal behavior and
of course we don't get to see this all
in one shot where he could take in the
scope of such a maneuver and it would
explain why they jumped into battle this
way
good to see Lucien clothed again he
found some other dead werewolf with his
exact tight-fitting leather pants I see
also can he not turn into a werewolf
again after doing it once seems like a
waste of such great fitting pants if he
can Victor somehow pulled this great
from the floor and escaped without
anyone seeing him in the middle of this
battle climactic battle between two
characters we know don't die is pretty
much exactly why these movies are
terrible Lucian's pulling on these
chains and letting sunlight come through
but wasn't it dark a minute ago hell I
guess all the vampires that the
werewolves are fighting outside are
probably dead now right thank you oh
this is such an empty ruin we only saw
one moment where Lucien felt affection
for his vampire dad and that was a brief
moment during the narration part of the
movie so this room is weaksauce this
should kill Victor but I've seen
underworld also why not just stick him
in the middle of the daylight let him
burn to death geez man don't you know
vampires by now hey we won the Sun came
out during the battle I mean I guess
that's what happened the movie never
showed us because once the two main
characters start fighting movies don't
give a sh about the bigger battle
happening away from them it is finished
no this is just the beginning
unfortunately also I'm a little confused
on this timeline an underworld evolution
we see Victor Marcus and Amelia capture
William the first werewolf this is
obviously before Victor and the others
started taking turns leading the coven
while the others hibernate but in rise
of the Lycans the other two are
hibernating suggesting misses after they
captured William and put him in prison
but the problem is Victor commissioned
Celine's father to build Williams prison
and it's pretty clear Selene and her
family don't exist yet now maybe this
happens later but this movie is making
it clear Lucien is the main werewolf so
I don't know why the vampires care so
much about William after this I'm just
saying the timelines of these movies
seem kind of this is the votanis took
out a minute ago but where is captain
they're sailing this thing during the
day so someone has to be steering the
boat right he's the one who killed your
finally not the Lycans underworld were
pries also none of this bull was
revelatory we know Victor killed
Celine's family because that was a huge
plot point of the first two movies and
we know he didn't kill her because she
reminded him of Sonya so why are we
making it seem like a huge reveal now
that the movie needs some padding kinky
I like my sex away I play basketball one
on one and with his little dribbling as
possible he created a new race of
immortals
keep your eyes on the ground
you will spend an eternity on this
there's a new life waiting beyond these
walls my friend and you can be a part of
it one of us I will come back I promise
here stay alive no matter what I throw I
will find you
[Music]
I have something he wants they have
something I want no funny don't just
just look at me keep your eyes on me
Sonia look at me don't look right keep
your eyes shut